promixité vous est présenté par ngj
acteur engagé en faveur de l'égalité
[Musique]
professionnelle bonjour à tous et
bienvenue dans promixité l'émission qui
vous parle de la place des femmes dans
le monde du travail aujourd'hui focus
sur l'Islande pays le plus égalitaire au
monde depuis 14 ans selon le forum
économieque mondiale pourtant selon le
quotidien britannique The guardians les
femmes y gagnent toujours 21 % de moins
que les hommes et elles sont plus de 40
% à avoir déjà subi des violences
sexistes et sexuelles et c'est justement
pour protester que des milliers de
femmes se sont mis en grève le 24
octobre dernier à l'occasion de la
gvenafri la journée libre pour les
femmes où il était autant question de
cesser le travail que les tâches
domestiques et figurez-vous que même la
première ministre s'est jointe au
mouvement une FO façon pour elle de
montrer sa solidarité avec les
islandaises alors que l'écart salarial
s'est creusé ces dernières années au
niveau de l'état des collectivité et du
secteur privé en 1975 la première
gvenafri avait mobilisé 90 % des
islandaises et elle avait conduit à des
changements décisifs comme l'élection de
la première femme présidente du pays
voilà promixité c'est fini pour
aujourd'hui on se retrouve très vite sur
Public
Sénat prier it vous a été présenté par
NG acteur engagé en faveur de l'égalité
professionnelle